Um, question coming. I just got my right machine, uh, how close do you put the light, um,
to next to your body? Well, it depends on if you have the amplifier connected. So if you have
that jack hammer amplifier connected to it, then you could put the ball underneath the bed.
Because it'll go right through the mattress and it'll affect you a beneficially. Now the amplifier
is a relatively new addition to the right machines. So, uh, uh, uh, most of our patients don't have
that. Don't have the jackhammer. So they're putting the ball right next to them. They're snugly
with the ball. But if you have the amplifier, it amplifies the frequency. So it gives it more power.
So if you do put the ball right next to you with the amplifier connected, you might experience
some static electricity. Somebody might come, your wife might come and give you a kiss and she gets
shocked, okay? It's just static electricity. It's not dangerous. It's, uh, it's, uh,
electrostatic electricity. Electrons are forming on the outside of your body. So there's nothing
harmful. It's just like when you rub your feet with your socks on on the carpet and then you go touch
something. Actually, electrons are attaching to the outside of your body and then discharging when
you touch something else. So there's no harm in that. But, um, it's not very comfortable, you know,
if somebody your wife reaches over and gets shocked every time she touches you or something like that.
So the reason why you would use the amplifier is because maybe you don't, you don't like
the ball next to you. You want it under your bed. There's maybe reasons why you'd want it under
your bed. You don't want it right next to you. Um, personally, I don't use the amplifier. And
again, most of our patients don't use the amplifier and they just take that off and then just use it,
just the bulb connected directly to the machine, red and black connector, the red black outlet on
the machine. And then you put the bulb just next to you in your bed. Um, that's my preferred way.
The only reason why I would tell somebody to use the amplifier and to put the bulb under the bed
is if they just, you know, have issues with anything in bed with them or they don't sleep with covers
on it all, the light is annoying or something like that.